Welcome everyone. We're going to start you off with a couple of nice softballs here brought to you by Shecky Hayes. My wife asked me the other day where I got so much candy. I said, I always have a few twicks up my sleeve. Boy. Well, now hang on. We got one more.
大家好。我们先从谢基·海耶斯（Shecky Hayes）带来的几个轻松的笑话开始。前几天我妻子问我哪来那么多糖果。我说，我袖子里总藏着几块“Twix”（双子星巧克力棒）。天哪。好吧，等等。我们还有一个。
Listeners. I can do a hundred more. I can do a hundred more. Save yourself. Here's another one. Ugh, I hate my job. All I do is crush cans all day. It's soda pressing. Huh? Welcome to Smartless. I went to go see a Broadway show last night, Shaunie, and I thought about you.
听众朋友们。我还能讲一百个。我还能讲一百个。救救你自己吧。再来一个。呃，我讨厌我的工作。我整天都在压碎易拉罐。这真是“苏打压力”（Soda pressing，谐音“令人沮丧”）。哈？欢迎来到《Smartless》。昨晚我去看了一场百老汇演出，肖尼，我想到你了。
What did you see? I saw Oh Mary. Oh, and? You did see it. I did. It's the best. Okay, I was going to recommend it to you, but you've seen best. Okay, I was gonna recommend it to you, but you've seen it.
你看了什么？我看了《哦，玛丽》（Oh, Mary）。哦，然后呢？你确实看了。我看了。太棒了。好吧，我本来想推荐给你的，但你已经看过最好的了。好吧，我本来想推荐给你的，但你已经看过了。
Yeah, I've seen it, yeah. Did you think, I loved it. I thought it was one of the funniest things I've ever seen in my life. I was thinking about you the whole time, thinking, oh my God, Sean's gonna lose his fucking mind on this. I mean, it seemed like he's,
是啊，我看过了。你觉得怎么样？我太喜欢了。我觉得这是我这辈子看过的最搞笑的东西之一。我全程都在想你，心想，天哪，肖恩看到这个肯定会疯掉的。我的意思是，看起来他，
I mean, I know he didn't, but it seemed like he's watched you do a thousand of your funny bits in front of us and stolen them all. Oh no, no, Cole's an original. He's great. Cole Escola stars in Little Mary. That's the show I was telling you guys to go see in March.
我的意思是，我知道他没有，但看起来他好像看了你表演的一千个搞笑片段，然后把它们全偷走了。哦不，不，科尔（Cole）是原创的。他很棒。科尔·埃斯科拉（Cole Escola）主演了《小玛丽》。那就是我三月份告诉你们要去看的那场演出。
Yes, Will was first. Well, hang on guys, Will was first. Yeah. I didn't go. Have you not seen it yet, Will? You'll pee in your pants. So it was off-Broadway then, yes? Now it's on Broadway.
是的，威尔是第一个。好吧，等等伙计们，威尔是第一个。是啊。我没去。威尔，你还没看吗？你会笑尿裤子的。所以当时是在外百老汇，对吧？现在是在百老汇。
Yeah, right, yeah, Lord Tell. Yeah, Cole Escola plays Mary Todd Lincoln, who's an alcoholic wannabe cabaret star, and Abraham Lincoln, Abraham Lincoln doesn't let her leave the White House, so he hires an acting coach for her so she could just explore her artistic side. Don't reveal anymore.
是啊，没错，是的，洛德·泰尔（Lord Tell）。是的，科尔·埃斯科拉饰演玛丽·托德·林肯，一个酗酒的、想当歌舞明星的人，而亚伯拉罕·林肯不让她离开白宫，所以他为她雇了一位表演教练，让她可以探索自己的艺术一面。别再剧透了。
Okay, that's it. You're gonna do the spoilers. But how about the end? How funny was that? It's fucking great. It's just the whole thing is incredible. Yeah, that's it. You're gonna do the spoilers. But how about the end? How funny was that? It's fucking great. It's just the whole thing is incredible. Yeah, it was really funny. Yeah, yeah.
好吧，就这样。你要剧透了。但是结局呢？那有多好笑？太他妈棒了。整部戏都不可思议。是的，就这样。你要剧透了。但是结局呢？那有多好笑？太他妈棒了。整部戏都不可思议。是的，真的很好笑。是啊，是啊。
Willie, you gotta get on it. Oh no, I really wanted to. You gotta get yourself, expose yourself to some culture, you know? Get out of- Wait, did Franny see it? She did, she and I, we had a date night. Did she like it? It was great.
威利，你得去看看。哦不，我真的很想看。你得让自己接触一下文化，你知道吗？走出——等等，弗兰妮（Franny）看了吗？她看了，她和我，我们有个约会之夜。她喜欢吗？太棒了。
Yeah, what do you, you got your hand on a bug there? Are you pulling out? Yeah, I just gotta pull it out. Sean's got three hands in his hairdo right now. No, I had a mole removed. Just step on it, make sure you step on it. Look at that. You know, you don't have to do it
是啊，你，你手上有个虫子吗？你要把它拔出来吗？是啊，我得把它拔出来。肖恩现在头发里有三只手。不，我刚切除了一颗痣。踩死它，确保你踩死它。看那个。你知道，你不必在，
while we're doing the- Yeah, just try to pick your scalp while we're- What, you could have done it before, or you could have saved it after, we wouldn't have known. I forgot to take it off this morning, but I need to let the air get to it. How was your mole removal? It was good.
我们正在录制的时候做这个——是啊，试着在我们录制的时候抠你的头皮——什么，你本可以在之前做，或者之后再做，我们根本不会知道。我今早忘了把它取下来，但我需要让它透透气。你的痣切除手术怎么样？挺好的。
Painful? Yeah, no, it wasn't painful. It was big, my man was honking and he scraped it off. So this was a result of just a... Age. Well, you went in and you got yourself combed like a cat. You got checked for all your skin cancer hotspots. Yeah, but they grew out of...
疼吗？是啊，不，不疼。它很大，医生把它刮掉了。所以这是因为……年龄。好吧，你进去之后像只猫一样被梳理了一遍。你检查了所有皮肤癌的高发区域。是啊，但它们长出来是因为……
You mean like a chimp? You mean like when they do like that? Everybody's gotta do that, by the way, we're joking, but get yourself in there and get yourself checked if you're of a certain age. It's true, and vote. We do a lot of damage when we're like 20. And get out there and fucking vote.
你是说像黑猩猩那样？你是说像它们那样做？顺便说一句，每个人都得做那个，我们是在开玩笑，但如果你到了某个年纪，一定要去检查一下。这是真的，还有去投票。我们在20岁左右的时候对自己造成了很多伤害。走出去，他妈的去投票。
Yeah, and then go ahead and vote. Or vote at the place you get checked. Whoever, yeah, whoever. By the way, that'd be great if they did that. While you were waiting. Yeah, vote. They oughta do stuff like that where you can get, bring back shit where you can kind of get
是啊，然后去投票。或者在你检查的地方投票。不管是谁，是啊，不管是谁。顺便说一句，如果他们能那样做就太好了。当你等待的时候。是啊，投票。他们应该做些这样的事情，让你能，带回一些东西，让你能，某种程度上，
a bunch of different shit done at once. You can get a moment. Or how about just declare election day a national holiday? Then let me tell you something. I know our surprise guest is a female. I can tell you that right now. I can hear her enjoying and giggling. There's another one.
一次性完成一堆不同的事情。你可以腾出一点时间。或者干脆把选举日定为国定假日怎么样？那我就告诉你吧。我知道我们的惊喜嘉宾是一位女性。我现在就可以告诉你。我能听到她在享受和咯咯笑。又来一个。
There's another one. But yes, it should be a national holiday. Obviously it should be a national holiday for all the obvious reasons. But at the same time, imagine if you could, on that day, get a bunch of stuff done. If you wanted to get a Brazilian, you could do that too. Oh, here we go.
又来一个。但是是的，它应该是一个国定假日。显然，出于所有显而易见的原因，它应该是一个国定假日。但与此同时，想象一下，如果你在那一天能完成一堆事情。如果你想做个巴西式脱毛，你也可以做。哦，开始了。
Shampoo, shampoo coach. I'm just saying, whatever your thing is. Shampoo, and then in the back, you could do whatever you want. Oh, here we go, shamp, shamp-coach. I'm just saying, if whatever your thing is. Shampoo-ch, and then in the back, you can go ahead and get yourself a shamp-coach. Yeah. So, so that was Ali's bit. My buddy Ali used to do shamp-coach, and in the back you put your,
洗发，洗发教练（Shampoo-ch）。我只是说，不管你想要什么。洗发，然后在后面，你可以做任何你想做的事。哦，开始了，洗发，洗发教练。我只是说，不管你想要什么。洗发教练，然后在后面，你可以去给自己做一个洗发教练。是啊。所以，那是阿里的段子。我的哥们阿里过去常做洗发教练，在后面你放你的，
you bring your pet and they get a shampoo-ch. Anyway. Yeah, in the front it's a, it's a, it's a, Brazilian. Yeah, you get your dog wash. Yeah, shampoo-ch. No, the front, I think it's the, it depends. No, the pet Yeah, it's a shank coach. It depends. No, the pet would be the front, the front place.
你带上你的宠物，它们就能得到一个洗发教练。总之。是啊，前面是一个，一个，一个，巴西式脱毛。是啊，你给你的狗洗澡。是啊，洗发教练。不，前面，我想是，这取决于。不，宠物，是啊，那是洗发教练。这取决于。不，宠物应该是前面，前面的地方。
Sean, go ahead Sean, sorry. Whenever you order food for takeout, like from a restaurant, do you sometimes order extra so you don't have to, like as a grocery shopping, kind of? So like you- Wait, what? Wait a second, dude. I was just getting a Brazilian and now you're talking about shopping via-
肖恩，继续吧肖恩，抱歉。当你点外卖时，比如从餐馆点餐，你有时会多点一些，这样你就不用，就像去杂货店购物一样，对吧？所以你——等等，什么？等一下，伙计。我刚才还在做巴西式脱毛，现在你在谈论通过……购物？
Now you're talking about getting cash back when you get groceries? What's going on? No, no, no. When you go, when you order... Yeah, can I get 18 bucks? What are you doing? No, when you order takeout from a restaurant, sometimes I'll order an extra meal or something, put it in the fridge.
现在你在谈论买杂货时获得现金返还？怎么回事？不，不，不。当你去，当你点……是啊，我能拿18块钱吗？你在干什么？不，当你从餐馆点外卖时，有时我会多点一份餐什么的，放进冰箱。
So, like my quote, grocery shopping, so that I don't have to, so that I just have a meal I could pop in the microwave. Wait, how long have you been in college? What are you doing, man? It's true. That's what I do. Instead of grocery shopping, you just order an extra meal. America, this is spoken to you by a guy who's got a full-time chef.
所以，就像我所谓的，杂货购物，这样我就不用，这样我就有一顿饭可以放进微波炉里。等等，你上大学多久了？你在干什么，伙计？这是真的。我就是这么做的。与其去杂货店购物，你只是多点了一份餐。美国，这是一个有全职厨师的人对你说的。
Yeah. Okay. So I don't. My full-time chef is me and five days a week. Sorry. Oh my God. So is she offended at all that you're doubling up attention because you don't have confidence in her? No, fucking, Shawnee, I never knew this about you. This is phenomenal information.
是啊。好吧。所以我没有。我的全职厨师是我自己，一周五天。抱歉。天哪。那么她是否因为你加倍关注而感到被冒犯，因为你对她没信心？不，他妈的，肖尼，我从来不知道你这一点。这是惊人的信息。
Always order an extra meal. Is this your way, because sometimes you feel bad because you've ordered so much food so you justify it by saying, it's for tomorrow. Yeah, something like that, yeah. Wait, Shawnee, are you in New York? Is that New York behind you? Yeah, yeah.
总是多点一份餐。这是你的方式吗，因为有时你觉得不好意思，因为你点得太多了，所以你通过说“这是明天的”来证明它是合理的？是啊，差不多是这样，是啊。等等，肖尼，你在纽约吗？你身后是纽约吗？是啊，是啊。
Oh, how come we're not hanging out? What's going on? Well, because you work every day for 17,000 hours. But if you're not. JB, how you liking the weekend in the city, JB? It's the first weekend you've been there for a while. I'm not crazy about it, because I feel like I'm missing my wife
哦，为什么我们不聚聚？怎么回事？好吧，因为你每天工作17000个小时。但如果你不是的话。JB，你觉得在城里过周末怎么样，JB？这是你一段时间以来第一次在那里过周末。我不太喜欢，因为我觉得我错过了我的妻子
and my youngest daughter back in LA. I should have gone back and picked up Maple from a farm camp, so she was living at farm camp for a month up in Northern California, sleeping outside in a tent and taking care of her. Can I just say, and by the way, I think the farm camp is amazing, but can you imagine going back 150 years,
和我在洛杉矶的小女儿。我本应该回去把梅普尔（Maple）从农场夏令营接回来，她在北加州的一个农场夏令营住了一个月，睡在帐篷里，照顾她。我能说一下吗，顺便说一句，我觉得农场夏令营很棒，但你能想象回到150年前吗？
bringing somebody back from the past, and they come in, they go, who working on a farm, and they're like, what's this? It's farm camp. It's a camp. It's a bunch of kids from LA and New York, cause they don't know what it is. Trying to get exposed.
把某人从过去带回来，他们进来，他们说，谁在农场工作，他们就像，这是什么？这是农场夏令营。这是一个夏令营。这是一群来自洛杉矶和纽约的孩子，因为他们不知道那是什么。试图去接触一下。
They're coming here to play the farm. They're like, fuck. And these kids are slaving away. It's fun. They're like, did you go to school? Yeah, I went to school all the way till I was nine. Yeah. You know? Working on the farm until I was nine. Yeah. You know?
他们来这里玩农场。他们就像，该死。这些孩子在拼命干活。这很有趣。他们就像，你上学了吗？是啊，我一直上学到九岁。是啊。你知道吗？在农场工作到九岁。是啊。你知道吗？
Working on the farm. Farm camp. Farm camp. She had kitty chore. Guys, listen, we gotta get to our guest. She's just sitting here listening to us, wasting our fucking time. And Sean, you're gonna love this because,
在农场工作。农场夏令营。农场夏令营。她有小猫杂务。伙计们，听着，我们得请我们的嘉宾了。她就坐在那儿听我们说话，浪费我们他妈的时间。肖恩，你会喜欢这个的，因为，
yeah, she's done a lot of iconic stuff on TV, stuff that I can't really mention, even stuff that was my favorite, but she's done a lot of theater. She's been nominated for a bunch of Olivier. She's's done she played Blanche Dubois in Streetcar great acclaim in in the well she's sort of British kind of was raised there then moved back and now has lived there again for years but she was originally but Shawn but born in Chicago okay Shawn do you think she might have a story about maybe something crazy that happened on stage?
是啊，她在电视上做过很多标志性的事情，有些我真的不能提，甚至有些是我最喜欢的，但她做过很多戏剧。她获得过很多奥利弗奖提名。她演过《欲望号街车》里的布兰奇·杜波依斯，广受好评，在，嗯，她算是英国人，在那里长大，然后搬回来，现在又在那里住了几年，但她最初是，但肖恩，但出生在芝加哥，好吧肖恩，你觉得她可能有一个关于舞台上发生的疯狂事情的故事吗？
Oh my gosh, she's in Chicago? She better get ready with a story. Do you remember when we used to all hang out at Haney's and she, did you ever go to Haney's in Chicago? And then, so she's won all these awards, she's been nominated for all this stuff, she's done dozens of films, but I loved her in that amazing series, The Fall, but I also loved her in the amazing series,
天哪，她在芝加哥？她最好准备好一个故事。你还记得我们过去常在海尼（Haney's）聚会的时候，她，你去过芝加哥的海尼吗？然后，所以她赢得了所有这些奖项，她被提名了所有这些东西，她拍了几十部电影，但我喜欢她在那个惊人的系列剧《堕落》（The Fall）中的表现，但我也喜欢她在那个惊人的系列剧，
The Crown, but I also loved her as, and everybody else said, as the amazing FBI special agent, Dana Scully. Guys, please, it's Gillian Anderson! No way! Gillian Anderson's in the team. Did you almost say special anus? I think you almost said special anus, Scully.
《王冠》（The Crown）中的表现，但我也喜欢她作为，正如其他人所说，作为那个惊人的FBI特别探员，达娜·斯卡利（Dana Scully）。伙计们，请欢迎，是吉莲·安德森（Gillian Anderson）！不会吧！吉莲·安德森在团队里。你刚才是不是差点说成“特别肛门”（special anus）？我想你差点说成“特别肛门，斯卡利”。
Well, that's what the notes gave me. I made the correction but they sent me that. Hello Jillian. Oh my God. You guys are hilarious. Oh my God, you guys are so funny. Thank you so much for being here. This is so cool.
好吧，那是笔记给我的。我做了更正，但他们发给我那个。你好，吉莲。天哪。你们太搞笑了。天哪，你们太有趣了。非常感谢你能来。这太酷了。
And joining us on this blessed day. Go ahead Sean. I was just gonna say I've been such a fan for so long. I mean, I know you hear this all the time. I love all of your work. Thank you. But you know when you're a young person. But the one that really disappointed, sorry.
在这个神圣的日子里加入我们。继续吧，肖恩。我只是想说，我当你的粉丝已经很久了。我的意思是，我知道你经常听到这个。我喜欢你所有的作品。谢谢。但你知道当你年轻的时候。但那个真正让我失望的，抱歉。
No, just when you're a young person and stuff stays in your DNA, the X-Files is part of me. So therefore you are a part of me. So thank you. Well, I get it. The truth is out there, Sean. I can feel that. I woke up this morning feeling like I a part of me. So thank you. Yeah, I get it. The truth is out there, Shona. I woke up this morning feeling like I was part of you.
不，只是当你年轻的时候，有些东西留在了你的DNA里，《X档案》是我的一部分。因此，你是我的一个部分。所以谢谢你。好吧，我明白了。真相就在那里，肖恩。我能感觉到。我今天早上醒来时感觉我，你是我的一个部分。所以谢谢你。是啊，我明白了。真相就在那里，肖恩。我今天早上醒来时感觉我就是你的一部分。
What are the questions that you weren't asked about X-Files when you were publicizing that? I remember one time being, after one of the awards standing backstage, you know, where they take you backstage and then you've got that, the tier of, tiers of press back there. From the back row, somebody said,
当你在宣传《X档案》时，有哪些问题是你没被问到的？我记得有一次，在颁奖典礼后站在后台，你知道，他们把你带到后台，然后你就有那一排排的媒体。从后排，有人说，
do you believe in aliens? Which of course, by that point, I'd been asked every second of my life, and I think I might have said, are you fucking kidding me? I think I literally, out of my mouth, I was like, really? That's what you're going to fucking ask me? I'm standing here? Sean, you was like, really, that's what you're gonna fucking ask me? I'm standing here, I just, I don't know.
你相信外星人吗？当然，到那时为止，我这辈子每秒钟都被问到这个问题，我想我可能说，你他妈在开玩笑吗？我想我真的，脱口而出，我就像，真的吗？这就是你要他妈问我的问题？我站在这里？肖恩，你就像，真的吗，这就是你要他妈问我的问题？我站在这里，我只是，我不知道。
Sean, you do though, right? I absolutely do. You believe there's probably something out there. It probably doesn't look like the egg-shaped head, but it's probably some sort of... Yeah, anytime anything is on TV about, is there, isn't there, I watch it and I'm all into it. Right.
肖恩，你相信，对吧？我绝对相信。你相信外面可能有什么东西。它可能看起来不像蛋形的头，但它可能是一种……是啊，任何时候电视上有什么关于“有没有”的内容，我都会看，而且我完全沉浸其中。对。
Do you, and what is it, Sean, you're just, you find it like interesting, you find it exciting, you're hoping, you want to get out, are you trying to get off this globe? Yeah, no, I just think it's fascinating that the whole concept that we come from something we don't know, and I think there's answers there that hold on. I'd like for you to get abducted, like they reveal themselves and then they start
你，这是什么，肖恩，你只是，你觉得它很有趣，你觉得它很令人兴奋，你在希望，你想出去，你是想离开这个星球吗？是啊，不，我只是觉得很迷人，我们来自我们不知道的东西的整个概念，而且我认为那里有答案，等等。我希望你被绑架，就像他们揭示了自己，然后他们开始
to murder you, you're like, I thought you'd be fun and interesting. But are you saying that you think that alien life form, Sean, might be responsible for the start of mankind? By the way, jump in anytime you want to here. I do believe that. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Part of me believes that.
谋杀你，你就像，我以为你们会很有趣。但你是说你认为那个外星生命形式，肖恩，可能对人类的起源负责吗？顺便说一句，你想什么时候插话都可以。我确实相信这一点。等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。我的一部分相信这一点。
Part of me believes that, yeah. Whoa, wait, that mankind came from a higher, sort of more complex life form of sort of aliens and stuff, as opposed to the aliens and mankind coming from sort of like a God-like creator. I'm open to both. You think we come from the aliens. I'm open to both, but I lean towards the alien thing
我的一部分相信这一点，是啊。哇，等等，人类来自一种更高级、更复杂的生命形式，比如外星人之类的，而不是外星人和人类来自某种像上帝一样的创造者。我对两者都持开放态度。你认为我们来自外星人。我对两者都持开放态度，但我倾向于外星人的说法，
only because did you see Prometheus? Did you see the movie Prometheus? I think so. You mean the Hollywood feature film? No, but I saw Star Wars, how much of that is true? Fucking, what are you talking about? Please let Sean finish with this. You're right, you're right, you're right.
仅仅是因为你看过《普罗米修斯》（Prometheus）吗？你看过电影《普罗米修斯》吗？我想看过。你是说好莱坞故事片？不，但我看过《星球大战》，那有多少是真的？他妈的，你在说什么？请让肖恩说完这个。你是对的，你是对的，你是对的。
He's got the answers, guys. So Prometheus, uh-huh, uh-huh. There's two minutes, like, do you ever watch? I'm going to start writing this shit down. Do you ever watch Ancient Aliens? Do you ever watch Ancient Aliens? No.
他有答案，伙计们。所以《普罗米修斯》，嗯哼，嗯哼。有两分钟，就像，你看过吗？我要开始把这些东西写下来了。你看过《远古外星人》（Ancient Aliens）吗？你看过《远古外星人》吗？没有。
Oh, we watch it all the time. And all these theories about all the hieroglyphics that show, you know, engraved into the walls, about like the, you know, things, they're all looking up at these flying things, and they're all kind of similar. I think 20 of our episodes, 20 of our 220 episodes were about those hieroglyphics. Yeah, exactly. How far is your house from the nearest library, do you think? Anyway, Gillian, welcome.
哦，我们一直看。所有这些关于刻在墙上的象形文字的理论，你知道，关于，你知道，东西，它们都在抬头看这些飞行的东西，而且它们都差不多。我想我们的220集里有20集是关于那些象形文字的。是啊，没错。你觉得你的房子离最近的图书馆有多远？总之，吉莲，欢迎。
So welcome, Gillian. Gillian, speaking of extraterrestrials and stuff, the one thing I do want to ask you is, at what point, obviously X-Files played a huge part in the early part of your career, and you've gone on to do so many amazing things And I think of so many different things Yeah, I love the ground too, but it's one of those things and Sean you could kind of know what this is like and Jason You do too when you do something that is such a sort of hit that crosses all demographics, etc At a at a young age
所以欢迎，吉莲。吉莲，说到外星人之类的东西，我确实想问你的一件事是，在什么阶段，显然《X档案》在你职业生涯的早期扮演了重要角色，你后来做了很多惊人的事情，我想到了很多不同的事情，是啊，我也喜欢《堕落》，但这是其中之一，肖恩，你可以知道这感觉是什么样的，杰森，你也一样，当你做了一些在年轻时跨越所有人口统计学等等的某种热门作品时，
What when you look back on your experiences as X-Files, is it a positive feeling? Are you like, oh, that was the greatest thing? Or did it open all these millions of doors? Or is it, oh, this is what I'm using as a platform or something? It was, you know what happens when you're on a long-running show is everything becomes so enmeshed and not incestuous, but you literally feel like you're living and breathing
当你回顾你在《X档案》的经历时，这是一种积极的感觉吗？你就像，哦，那是最好的事情吗？还是它打开了所有这些数以百万计的门？或者它是，哦，这是我正在使用的平台之类的东西？是啊，你知道当你参加一个长期播出的节目时会发生什么，一切都变得如此纠缠，不是乱伦，但你真的觉得你在生活和呼吸，
this, you know, the entire crew, the entire experience. And so I think by the time we were done after, you know, we did nine years, and... Wow. Wow. I think I was well ready for it to be over. And it took me a while to properly think of it. I think I compartmentalized it. I so wanted to get off it and start doing the things
这个，你知道，整个剧组，整个经历。所以我认为当我们结束时，你知道，我们做了九年，而且……哇。哇。我想我已经准备好让它结束了。而且我花了一段时间才真正去思考它。我想我把它分门别类了。我太想摆脱它，开始做那些，
that I thought my career was going to be before I said yes to that job. So I imagined I'd be doing Merchant Ivory films and I imagine I'd be doing all this. And so I really wanted to, on the one hand, forget that that happened and bounce off it to the stuff that I really wanted to do. But then, you know, it was probably about five years
在我答应那份工作之前，我认为我的职业生涯会是什么样的事情。所以我想象我会拍默昌特-艾沃里（Merchant Ivory）的电影，我想象我会做所有这些。所以我真的想，一方面，忘记那件事发生过，并从它跳到我真正想做的事情上。但后来，你知道，那可能大约是五年，
when I suddenly, because when you're doing something like that, all anybody says is, oh my God, the show, oh my God, it's the most amazing. And you don't want to hear that anymore. You don't want to. You don't. You've heard it so much. And then I suddenly got what they were talking about
当我突然，因为当你做那样的事情时，所有人说的都是，天哪，那个节目，天哪，它是最惊人的。你不想再听到那个了。你不想。你不想。你听得太多了。然后我突然明白了他们在说什么，
like five years after the show ended. I was kind of like, yeah, that was kind of cool. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Like I was on this really cool show. Yeah, like anything you need time and distance away to appreciate. You do, yeah. But it is interesting how like the things that sort of like landed all four of us with a career are things that I'll bet you
在节目结束后大约五年。我当时就像，是啊，那挺酷的。是啊，是啊，是啊。就像我参加了一个真的很酷的节目。是啊，就像任何你需要时间和距离来欣赏的东西一样。你需要，是啊。但有趣的是，像我们四个人都获得职业生涯的东西，我敢打赌，
none of us would have said this would be the exact thing that would condition the audience and the industry to the kind of person and career I wanna have. That's exactly right. And it's like you basically, it's not that you take what you get, but you're appreciative of the job at the time, but then by the time you're done with the job at the time, but then by the time
我们中没有人会说这正是会塑造观众和行业对我想要的那种人和职业生涯的东西。那完全正确。就像你基本上，不是说你接受你得到的，但你在当时很感激这份工作，但当你做完这份工作时，但当你，
you're done with the job, guess what? That's who you are now. And now what do I do with this? And this is, I hope I don't sound like I'm complaining at all, because I could not be more appreciative of, you know, as I'm sure you guys would agree where we're at and what, but you tack towards what you're now identified and labeled as and build on that or try to offset that a little bit and have a little bit more of a different kind of career. It's like.
做完这份工作时，猜猜怎么着？那就是现在的你。现在我该怎么处理这个？这是，我希望我听起来不像是在抱怨，因为我再感激不过了，你知道，我相信你们会同意我们所处的位置和什么，但你倾向于你现在被识别和贴标签的东西，并在此基础上建立，或者稍微抵消一下，拥有一个稍微不同类型的职业生涯。就像。
But you need time to reckon with it. You need time and space to be able to figure out what it actually means to you because for the last however long, you've been hearing what it means to everybody else. And you know. But, you know, I... But we have those people on here all the time, Julian, that have been fortunate enough to do what you do,
但你需要时间来面对它。你需要时间和空间来弄清楚它对你到底意味着什么，因为在过去的很长一段时间里，你一直在听它对别人意味着什么。而且你知道。但是，你知道，我……但我们经常有这些人在这里，吉莲，他们足够幸运能做你做的事情，
which is you actually have gone on and created the whole identity for yourself as an actress, as one of the leading voices and actresses in the business. And X-Files just happens to be one of the jobs you've done, as opposed to the thing that identifies you. But it takes a while, it takes focus, it takes saying no to a lot of stuff, but it also, I remember at the beginning,
那就是你实际上已经继续前进，并为自己创造了作为一名女演员的整个身份，作为业内领先的声音和女演员之一。而《X档案》恰好是你做过的工作之一，而不是定义你的东西。但这需要时间，需要专注，需要对很多事情说不，但它也，我记得在开始的时候，
one of the first things that I, because after the series ended, I didn't know if I could be on a set again, I didn't know that for myself. It just felt, I knew that I just needed to get away from Los Angeles and set. So I had grown up in London, I moved back to London and the first thing I did was a play.
我做的第一件事之一，因为在系列结束后，我不知道我是否能再次出现在片场，我不知道我自己。它只是感觉，我知道我只是需要离开洛杉矶和片场。所以我是在伦敦长大的，我搬回了伦敦，我做的第一件事是一部戏。
But the second thing I did, I was offered was, you know, a British BBC, a short series of Bleak House and, you know, costume drama. And when they offered it to me, without an audition, I literally, in the meeting with the producers, I said to them, what makes you think I can do this? Because I knew I could do it, but I just spent 10 years doing exactly the opposite of that.
但第二件事，我被提供的是，你知道，一部英国BBC，一部短剧《荒凉山庄》（Bleak House），你知道，古装剧。当他们提供给我时，没有试镜，我真的，在与制片人的会议中，我对他们说，是什么让你认为我能做到这一点？因为我知道我能做到，但我刚花了10年时间做完全相反的事情。
And I was so curious. What did you see in me that I didn't? Yeah, that I feel like maybe has been lost or that nobody, yeah, so. And what did they say, do you remember? Oh, I'm sorry, we thought you were. Yeah, we think, yeah. We like to watch people fail.
而且我很好奇。你在我身上看到了什么我没看到的？是啊，我觉得可能已经丢失了，或者没有人，是啊，所以。他们说了什么，你还记得吗？哦，对不起，我们以为你是。是啊，我们认为，是啊。我们喜欢看人失败。
I can't remember what they said. I mean, I think that somewhere in the work that I did at X-Files, they gleaned that I could act, as opposed to what I felt like I was doing was not necessary. But of course I was. I mean, they were, you know, we got to, we learned how to be actors during that period of time. Right. We'll be right back.
我不记得他们说了什么。我的意思是，我认为在我《X档案》的工作中，他们推断出我能演戏，而不是我觉得我在做的事情是不必要的。但当然我是。我的意思是，他们是，你知道，我们学会了在那段时间里成为演员。对。我们马上回来。
And now back to the show. Where did you grow up in Chicago, by the way? Here we go. Well, I kinda, I kinda didn't. I was born there. Six months later, we moved to Puerto Rico because my story goes that my dad wanted to go to film school and he said to my mom, I want to go to film school,
现在回到节目。顺便问一下，你在芝加哥哪里长大的？开始了。好吧，我有点，我有点没在那儿长大。我出生在那里。六个月后，我们搬到了波多黎各，因为我的故事是，我爸爸想去电影学校，他对妈妈说，我想去电影学校，
do you want it to be Los Angeles, do you want to move to Los Angeles or London? And she said London. And so they didn't have any money to move to London and so we left the apartment, apparently moved to Puerto Rico where my dad's parents were living. And we basically slept on their sofa for a year and a half
你想是洛杉矶，你想搬到洛杉矶还是伦敦？她说伦敦。所以他们没有钱搬到伦敦，所以我们离开了公寓，显然搬到了波多黎各，我爸爸的父母住在那里。我们基本上在他们的沙发上睡了一年半，
so my parents could save money and we could move to London. So I only got like six months there. Do you remember where you were born? Yeah, at St. Mary's Hospital in Cook County. Oh yeah. I actually ended up back there because when I went to college, I moved to like Wicker Park, Bucktown area
这样我父母就能存钱，我们就能搬到伦敦。所以我只在那里待了六个月。你记得你出生在哪里吗？是啊，在库克县的圣玛丽医院。哦是啊。我实际上最终回到了那里，因为当我上大学时，我搬到了像威克公园（Wicker Park）、巴克镇（Bucktown）地区，
before it was Wicker Park, Bucktown. It was still low-income Hispanic families. And how long were you in England? Until I was 11. So from about a year and a... From 2 to 11. And your dad went to film school then, yes? When you were in London.
在它成为威克公园、巴克镇之前。它仍然是低收入的西班牙裔家庭。你在英国待了多久？直到我11岁。所以从大约一岁多……从2岁到11岁。你爸爸那时去电影学校了，是吗？当你在伦敦的时候。
And your dad, was he an editor? Is that right? No, no, we'll see, he wanted to be a cameraman. He wanted to be a director, a filmmaker. And after, but then they fell in love with London. We were always going to stay. We eventually could afford to rent a decent two-bedroom apartment. And so we stayed and he got various jobs
你爸爸，他是剪辑师吗？那是对的吗？不，不，我们要看，他想成为摄影师。他想成为导演，电影制作人。而在那之后，但后来他们爱上了伦敦。我们总是要留下来。我们最终负担得起租一套体面的两居室公寓。所以我们留下来了，他得到了各种工作，
working in various places. And then he got you know various jobs working in various places and and then he got a call from a film school friends and a fellow American who basically said I am starting to make industrial films come to Grand Rapids Michigan and get rich quick and he he said, okay, I'm going to do that. So he went out and we ended up moving to Grand Rapids. We went from London to Grand Rapids, Michigan. Wow. And there you stayed until?
在各种地方工作。然后他得到了，你知道，在各种地方工作，然后他接到了电影学校朋友和一个美国同胞的电话，他基本上说，我开始制作工业电影了，来大急流城（Grand Rapids），密歇根州，快速致富，他，他说，好吧，我要做那个。所以他去了，我们最终搬到了大急流城。我们从伦敦搬到了密歇根州的大急流城。哇。你在那里待到？
Until I went to college, yeah. Which was where? To the Goodman Theater School in Chicago. Oh, in Chicago. So then your spark was kind of lit by your father's interest in the business? Is that kind of how it started? No, I don't think it was. I think the high school that I went to in Grand Rapids, there was an English teacher.
直到我上大学，是啊。那是哪里？去芝加哥的古德曼戏剧学校（Goodman Theater School）。哦，在芝加哥。所以你的火花是被你父亲对这个行业的兴趣点燃的？那是怎么开始的吗？不，我不这么认为。我认为我在大急流城上的高中，有一位英语老师。
It was an academic high school. And I've said this so many times, but the only reason I got in was because I had an accent. I've been asked this so many times, she would direct a play that would be put on in the lunch room. And at one point, I think we did Our Town. I can't remember who I played, but I think it was for the policemen. In the middle of grilled cheeses and like french fries. Yeah, exactly. Any fun stories from the luncheon?
那是一所学术型高中。我已经说过很多次了，但我能进去的唯一原因是因为我有口音。我被问过很多次了，她会导演一部在午餐室上演的戏。有一次，我想我们演了《小镇》（Our Town）。我不记得我演了谁，但我想是警察。在烤奶酪和炸薯条中间。是啊，没错。午餐室有什么有趣的故事吗？
Sean, you had to care whether they're theater or food related. Either is fine with him. No, but I remember asking for another sandwich so I could take it home later and have it for another meal. I remember. I did that when I was in high school. I identified with each one. Great callback. Yeah. and have it for another meal. I remember I did that when I was in high school. I identified with the Eastman.
肖恩，你得关心它们是戏剧还是食物相关的。对他来说都行。不，但我记得要了另一个三明治，这样我以后可以带回家，作为另一顿饭。我记得。我在高中时做过。我认同每一个。很棒的回调。是啊。并作为另一顿饭。我记得我在高中时做过。我认同伊斯特曼。
Yeah, anyway, so I think that was probably what ended up getting me interested. And then I started auditioning for community theater and stuff. Wow. I love the Goodman Theater. I did a play there a few years ago. It's so great. What was the first gig that you got that you were like,
是啊，总之，所以我认为那可能就是让我感兴趣的原因。然后我开始为社区剧院之类的东西试镜。哇。我喜欢古德曼剧院。我几年前在那里演过一部戏。太棒了。你得到的第一个演出是什么，让你觉得，
oh, you know what, I can really do this. I think that I, not I can do this, not that I have the ability, but this is gonna be, I can have a life doing this. I can have a career, I can make a living. Well, I think one of the community shows that I auditioned for and was cast in, you know, it was the first time
哦，你知道吗，我真的能做到这一点。我想我，不是我能做到这一点，不是我有能力，而是这将是，我能靠这个生活。我能有职业生涯，我能谋生。好吧，我想我试镜并被录用的社区演出之一，你知道，这是第一次，
that I wased for and was cast in. It was the first time that I was properly doing something professional. And there must have been, I think I suddenly felt like, oh, I can actually do this. I can do this. There is something I can do. And it really changed my life around. Do you remember what it was?
我试镜并被录用。这是第一次我真正做专业的事情。而且一定有，我想我突然觉得，哦，我真的能做到这一点。我能做到。有什么是我能做的。它真的改变了我的生活。你记得那是什么吗？
Yeah, it was, um, it was Ander Knightingale Sang. It was a British, um, I think a World War II play. Yeah. And, uh, but anyway, you know, the applause or whatever got to me. How old were you? 16, I think. Wow, 16.
是啊，它是，嗯，它是《夜莺在歌唱》（And a Nightingale Sang）。这是一部英国的，嗯，我想是一部二战剧。是啊。而且，嗯，总之，你知道，掌声什么的触动了我。你多大？我想16岁。哇，16岁。
That's young to have that kind of... Well, all of a sudden, before that, I was sitting on the back steps with the smoking weeds in my lunch breaks and not doing my homework and suddenly something in that, in the inspiration and feeling like suddenly I had a purpose, it kind of shifted everything around and I started doing better in school
那么年轻就有那种……好吧，突然之间，在那之前，我坐在后阶梯上，在午休时间抽大麻，不做作业，突然之间，那种灵感和感觉，好像我突然有了目标，它改变了一切，我开始在学校表现得更好，
and I was voted most improved student. And suddenly I was, I went from the- It's kind of a back-ended compliment, by the way. Yeah. When the only way is up. Hey, you know what? You're not an idiot. Hey, but the reason I ask that is because, like, JB, you grew up doing this,
我被评为进步最大的学生。突然之间，我从——顺便说一句，这是一种反向的赞美。是啊。当唯一的路是向上时。嘿，你知道吗？你不是白痴。嘿，但我问那个的原因是因为，像，JB，你从小就做这个，
so you always knew that it was a viable thing, but for people like us who don't come out, who weren't born into it, there is that moment, Sean, I don't know, I asked you the same thing, which is that moment where you're like, I think there are plenty of people who I grew up with who never thought that I would ever be able to make a life out of doing this.
所以你一直知道这是一件可行的事情，但对于像我们这样没有出来，没有出生在里面的人来说，有那个时刻，肖恩，我不知道，我问过你同样的事情，那就是你觉得你像的时刻，我想我一起长大的很多人从来没想过我能靠做这个谋生。
You have lots of good friends who go, yeah, you could... But a lot of people are like, yeah, nice try. It's a big fucking scary world. Like, good luck. Yeah, well, my dad... I mean, I think when I started to audition for theater schools... I mean, I auditioned for one. It didn't occur to me that I wasn't going to get in.
你有很多好朋友说，是啊，你可以……但很多人就像，是啊，祝你好运。这是一个他妈的巨大的可怕的世界。就像，祝你好运。是啊，好吧，我爸爸……我的意思是，我想当我开始为戏剧学校试镜时……我的意思是，我试镜了一所。我没想到我进不去。
Like, I didn't have a Plan B. So I auditioned for the Goodman Theater School. Meanwhile, I only take 20 people every year. I didn't... I don't know what I would have done if I didn't get in. and have a plan B. study word processing because he knew that computers were going to be a thing and that I could always get a job on the side when I wasn't acting or able to act or getting hired so that I'd be able to teach people how to do word processing, to help them on their computers, which is a fantastic piece of advice for somebody else.
就像，我没有B计划。所以我试镜了古德曼戏剧学校。同时，我每年只招20个人。我没有……我不知道如果我没进去我会做什么。并且有B计划。学习文字处理，因为他知道计算机将成为一种东西，而且我可以在我不演戏或无法演戏或没被雇佣时在旁边找份工作，这样我就能教人们如何做文字处理，帮助他们使用计算机，这对别人来说是一个很棒的建议。
There was no way in hell that I was going to, never, my brain just doesn't work that way. But it was a great piece of advice. And the kinds of things that I'm saying to my sons right now. You know what I mean? Like have a contingency plan. Yeah. But you know, this part of people's lives,
我绝对不可能，从来没有，我的大脑不是那样工作的。但这是一个很好的建议。而且我现在对我儿子们说的那种话。你知道我的意思吗？就像有一个应急计划。是啊。但你知道，人们生活中的这一部分，
I'm surprised there's not more stories about or movies about or TV shows about, because there's tons of movies and TV shows about falling in love or deciding to have children or grappling with mortality and here comes death and somebody's got a terminal diagnosis. No one ever does anything about that moment where every young adult has that scary question about what am I going to do with my life? Who am I gonna be?
我很惊讶没有更多关于它的故事或电影或电视节目，因为有很多关于坠入爱河或决定生孩子或与死亡搏斗的电影和电视节目，死亡来了，有人被诊断出绝症。从来没有人做过关于那个时刻的事情，每个年轻人都有那个关于我这辈子要做什么的恐怖问题？我要成为谁？
Who am I going to be? Is it going to, should I pursue something that I'm passionate about, to the extent that you even know what you're passionate about yet at that age, or should I pursue something that's going to give me a path towards providing? Yeah, but doesn't that feel like an idea from the 1980s or something?
我要成为谁？它会，我应该追求我热衷的东西吗，达到你在这个年纪甚至知道你热衷于什么的程度，还是我应该追求能给我提供路径的东西？是啊，但这听起来不像1980年代的想法吗？
These days it's different. I guess it is, but there't that feel like an idea from the 1980s or something? These days it's different. I guess it is, but there's always jumping off points and everybody has a different height from which they're jumping off. There's more different risk involved. But just choosing what that lane is, what the industry is, what like, it is so important. It's like one of the biggest forks in anyone's life.
这些天不同了。我想是这样，但这听起来不像1980年代的想法吗？这些天不同了。我想是这样，但总有跳跃点，每个人跳跃的高度都不同。涉及的风险更不同。但仅仅选择那条车道是什么，行业是什么，就像，这太重要了。这就像任何人生命中最大的分叉之一。
What you're going to actually put your weight behind and choose to study in college or take that first job after college or before or during college. Like, you know, I've got a 17 year old and a 12 year old and like they're dealing with that right now. Willie, I'm sure, you know, your boys are thinking about it as well. It's like, it's like a big, big fork. Do you go left or right?
你实际上要投入什么，并选择在大学学习什么，或者在大学之后或之前或期间接受第一份工作。就像，你知道，我有一个17岁的和一个12岁的，他们现在正在处理这个问题。威利，我相信，你知道，你的孩子们也在考虑这个问题。这就像，这就像一个巨大的，巨大的分叉。你向左走还是向右走？
And Scotty's going through it too. Scotty's going through it too. That's my husband, Julie. I mean, it's, but like, it's not something that people talk about a lot. Yeah, no, no, no, it's true. We all go through it as parents. We all experience that with them. But I always say that the younger you figure that out,
斯科蒂（Scotty）也在经历这个。斯科蒂也在经历这个。那是我的丈夫，吉莲。我的意思是，它，但就像，这不是人们经常谈论的事情。是啊，不，不，不，这是真的。我们作为父母都经历过。我们都和他们一起经历过。但我总是说，你越早弄清楚这一点，
the higher success rate, right? Yeah. The younger you are. Even if it doesn't end up being the thing that you do, it's like, I always say like a lot of stuff happens on your way to something else. Like if you're just driven and motivated to do something, it's okay if it doesn't end up being that,
成功率就越高，对吧？是啊。你越年轻。即使它最终不是你做的事情，就像，我总是说，很多事情发生在你去往别处的路上。就像如果你只是被驱动和激励去做某事，即使它最终不是那个也没关系，
but at least your feet are moving forward. Yeah, yeah, yeah, totally. Yeah, I remember moving to New York when I was 20, and I did not know a single person in New York, and I just thought, fuck it. Yeah, let's get started. Yeah, let's fucking go. I was in college. Let's get this and get started. And I dropped out, because I thought, fuck it. Yeah, let's get started. Yeah, let's fucking go. I was in college.
但至少你的脚在向前移动。是啊，是啊，是啊，完全正确。是啊，我记得我20岁时搬到纽约，我在纽约一个人都不认识，我只是想，去他的。是啊，让我们开始吧。是啊，让我们他妈的走吧。我在上大学。让我们得到这个并开始。我退学了，因为我想，去他的。是啊，让我们开始吧。是啊，让我们他妈的走吧。我在上大学。
It's already started. And I dropped out because I thought, wait, everybody's just kind of not, nobody has any real direction. They're getting really good at being a senior, a sixth year senior, a seventh year senior. Yeah, whatever it is. I'm glad a great people, but at the same time,
它已经开始了。我退学了，因为我想，等等，每个人都只是某种程度上没有，没有人有任何真正的方向。他们变得非常擅长成为大四学生，第六年大四学生，第七年大四学生。是啊，不管是什么。我很高兴有很棒的人，但与此同时，
I just thought like, fuck, there's a whole world out there. I want to get in it. I want to get in the world. But that's the thing that I think a lot of teens these days are, the thing of the whole world as an oyster, in a way that obviously that's a very privileged perspective to have, but I feel like kids these days, that's not necessarily the perspective that they have.
我只是想，该死，外面有一个完整的世界。我想进入它。我想进入这个世界。但这就是我认为现在很多青少年是，把整个世界当作牡蛎的事情，以一种显然那是一个非常特权的视角，但我感觉现在的孩子们，那不一定是他们拥有的视角。
It doesn't feel like that is what is on offer anymore. There's something, there's some, and I don't know what, you know, the degree to which- That it's harder or it's easier? No, harder. So many kids are floundering right now. So many teens are just, or young 20s. You wanna know why?
感觉那不再是提供的东西了。有一些，有一些，我不知道，你知道，程度……更难还是更容易？不，更难。现在很多孩子都在挣扎。很多青少年只是，或者20岁出头。你想知道为什么吗？
It's because of the- It's the fucking phones. It is, it is. I'm serious, I'm dead serious. It is, on the one hand, you're. It is. I'm dead serious. It is. On the one hand, you're seeing the world out there because everybody's posting them and their holidays on yachts and this, that, and the other, but it feels so unreachable and so it actually has the opposite effect, I think, for a lot of things.
是因为……是那些他妈的手机。确实，确实。我是认真的，我死心塌地地认真。确实，一方面，你。确实。我是认真的。确实。一方面，你正在看到外面的世界，因为每个人都在发布他们和他们的游艇假期，这个，那个，以及其他东西，但它感觉如此遥不可及，所以我认为，对于很多事情来说，它实际上产生了相反的效果。
Instead of aspirational, it's kind of... I couldn't agree more in this idea that you can kind of go into your phone and lose yourself into all four corners. You're not really experiencing anything. You're getting the micro dopamine hits and stuff. There are lots of books about it right now. But at the same time, you're not actually getting that real world experience that we all have the privilege of getting.
与其说是抱负，不如说是一种……我非常同意这种观点，即你可以沉浸在手机里，迷失在四个角落。你并没有真正体验任何东西。你只是在获得微小的多巴胺刺激之类的东西。现在有很多关于这方面的书。但与此同时，你并没有真正获得我们所有人都有幸拥有的那种现实世界体验。
And while you're looking at it, you're sitting next to your friend, not having a conversation while they're looking at somebody's life too. And obviously, as you say, there's tons of books written about it. But it's a really serious problem today. Yeah. Jillian, can I ask you, can I nerd out on The Fall? I love that show so much. And I wish it's one of those shows that I wish I could watch it again for the first time. Because I found it so engrossing. It was so gripping. And what was that process like? Your character was very intense on that show.
当你盯着手机看的时候，你正坐在朋友身边，却没在交流，而他们也在看别人的生活。显然，正如你所说，关于这个话题的书籍多如牛毛。但这确实是当今一个非常严重的问题。是的。吉莉安，我可以问你，我可以对《堕落》这部剧表现得像个书呆子吗？我太喜欢那部剧了。我真希望它是那种我能重温一遍，就像第一次看一样感觉的剧。因为它让我太着迷了。它太扣人心弦了。那样的过程是怎样的？你的角色在那部剧中非常强烈。
Well, it was, I mean, the premise is great. So in the show, you're with the serial killer for an equal amount of screen time, as you are. The superintendent detective who is tracking him, which is me. And I think it was the first time, I don't know whether it was the first time, but it felt quite unique that, you know, that set up felt quite unique at the time. And so it started, you know,
嗯，它的前提非常棒。在剧中，你和连环杀手有同样多的出镜时间，就像你和追踪他的警司侦探（也就是我）一样。我想这是第一次，我不知道是不是第一次，但那种设定在当时感觉非常独特。所以它开始于，你知道，
it started where I was brought a script and I'd been in the process of producing something myself that I couldn't just, I couldn't get there. I'd been in the process of producing something myself that I couldn't just, I couldn't get there. I was really, really struggling with the writers and the other producers to get the script to where it needed to be. And then this script landed in my lap and it was like, now that is, that is writing.
它开始于我拿到剧本的时候，当时我正在制作一些我无法完成的东西。我当时正在制作一些我无法完成的东西。我和编剧以及其他制片人为了让剧本达到预期的效果而苦苦挣扎。然后这个剧本落到了我手里，感觉就像，这才是写作。
And it was so spare, you know? It was just, it was so spare, you know? It was just, it was like, and I've spoken about this before, it felt like when I was reading it, my experience of the character, it almost, despite the fact that it was so spare, it felt like my fusion with her was almost alchemic.
而且它非常精炼，你知道吗？它非常精炼，你知道吗？它就像是，我以前也说过，当我读它的时候，我对这个角色的体验，尽管它非常精炼，但感觉我和她的融合几乎是炼金术般的。
And because there wasn't a lot to go on, in a typical American way of reading a script where it's all descriptions are in the directives in between where you get so much information you feel like you're slightly treated like an idiot. But this was really beautifully, beautifully spare and yet you just got who she was, what the world was, who the different voices were in it.
因为没有太多可供参考的内容，不像典型的美国剧本阅读方式，所有的描述都在指令之间，你得到的信息太多，感觉自己被当成了傻瓜。但这个剧本非常精美、非常精炼，然而你却能立刻明白她是谁，世界是什么样的，里面不同的声音是谁。
And it was, so it was really special. And, you know, I met them and, you know, the producers and the director, and it was a fantastic experience. You know, I'd just come off of, I don't know which version of which Hollywood thing I had just finished doing. But all of a sudden I was in Belfast
所以这真的很特别。而且，你知道，我见到了他们，制片人和导演，那是一次美妙的经历。你知道，我刚结束，我不知道我刚完成的是好莱坞的哪个版本。但突然之间我就在贝尔法斯特了，
shooting this little series and it was a real collaboration. You know, it was, I went from being on something where I was so detached and so not part of the creative process to all of a sudden being with these guys in Belfast and really immersed and included in the conversation and, you know, in the end got to make notes on the edit and all that kind of stuff. So it was the first time that
拍摄这个小系列，这真的是一次合作。你知道，我从一个我非常疏离、完全不参与创作过程的项目，突然之间和贝尔法斯特的这些人在一起，真正沉浸其中并参与到对话中，你知道，最后还能对剪辑提出意见等等。所以这是第一次
I was being allowed into that part of it. And, you know, if I wanted to go back to London you know it was a matter of texting the travel coordinator as opposed to sending an email to somebody at Fox and a month later they tell you that yes you are you you can and cannot take that flight so it felt like the whole experience of it was like this is this is what it this is the real thing you know this is what I want to do this is what I want to do. This is what I want to do. She was an extraordinary character. I felt for them, before it aired,
我被允许进入那个部分。而且，你知道，如果我想回伦敦，你知道，只需要给旅行协调员发个短信，而不是给福克斯的某个人发邮件，一个月后他们才告诉你，是的，你可以或不可以乘坐那次航班，所以整个体验感觉就像是，这就是真实的东西，你知道，这就是我想做的，这就是我想做的。这就是我想做的。她是一个非凡的角色。在播出之前，我为他们感到难过，
when I started to do press, I remember saying to the press who hadn't really seen it yet, they do or they don't watch the screeners at their scent. And I kept thinking, she's really good for women. Like she needs to be out there. There's something about her, I think, that is gonna be incredibly empowering for women.
当我开始做媒体宣传时，我记得我对那些还没看过剧的媒体说，他们看或不看寄给他们的样片。我一直觉得，她对女性真的很有好处。她需要被展现出来。我认为她身上有一些东西，会对女性产生难以置信的赋权作用。
And I don't think we've seen someone like her before on this screen. She had the same sort of impact to me as DCI Tennyson from Prime Suspect. There were a lot of similarities, very strong. I mean, you bring a lot of strength to your character. You played a bunch of very strong characters throughout your career, including Margaret Thatcher,
而且我不认为我们在屏幕上见过像她这样的人。她给我的影响和《头号嫌疑犯》中的田纳森警长一样。有很多相似之处，非常强大。我的意思是，你为你的角色带来了很多力量。你在整个职业生涯中扮演过很多非常强大的角色，包括玛格丽特·撒切尔，
I was gonna say. You kind of go from that to, not directly, you do stuff in between, but then you do, then you play Margaret Thatcher, which which in The Crown, to great acclaim and really just a wonderful performance. Incredible performance. And I just think that must bring with it its own set of risks and challenges and burdens.
我正想说。你从那个角色过渡到，不是直接过渡，中间做了一些别的事情，然后你扮演了玛格丽特·撒切尔，在《王冠》中，获得了巨大的赞誉，真的是一场精彩的表演。不可思议的表演。我只是觉得这一定带来了它自己的一套风险、挑战和负担。
And you invite a tremendous amount of criticism, right? The thing is, those kind of things come along and you can't not say yes. I mean, you know what I mean? I think I've always, you have to say yes to those things and then deal with your fear afterwards almost. And it's the same thing with doing theater is saying yes to things that are terrifying.
而且你招致了大量的批评，对吧？问题是，那种事情出现了，你无法拒绝。我的意思是，你知道我的意思吗？我想我一直认为，你必须对那些事情说“是”，然后几乎在事后处理你的恐惧。做戏剧也是一样，要对那些令人恐惧的事情说“是”。
And then at some point when you're halfway through rehearsal, you're feeling like, what the fuck was I thinking? What made me think that I could do this or that I shoulda known I'm stuck and I've gotta be do this in front of a thousand people every single night? Like, what is wrong with me?
然后在排练到一半的某个时刻，你会觉得，我到底在想什么？是什么让我觉得我能做到这一点，或者我应该知道我被困住了，我必须每天晚上在几千人面前做这件事？我到底怎么了？
Or then it's over and you've crushed it and now you've got the confidence and now you're ready to take on even something bigger. The next thing that you get to say yes to because yeah, that's what it's about. I've always thought that the confidence about stuff lives on the backside of actually doing it. You know, it's completely appropriate
或者当它结束了，你成功了，现在你有了信心，现在你准备好迎接更大的挑战了。下一件你可以说“是”的事情，因为是的，这就是它的意义所在。我一直认为，关于某件事的信心来自于实际去做它之后。你知道，这是完全恰当的，
that you're fearful beforehand and that you shouldn't worry about the fact that you're not confident going into it because confident lives on the backside of actually executing. Like once you've done it, you've kind of. And then it gives you courage enough to say yes to the thing next time that is even a bit scarier. Or you don't worry about the result
你在事前感到恐惧，你不应该担心你在进入它时没有信心，因为信心来自于实际执行之后。就像一旦你做到了，你就……然后它给了你足够的勇气，在下一次对更可怕的事情说“是”。或者你不担心结果，
and you just do the work. Oh, Sean. Amen, brother. Thank you, amen. I think for Thatcher, it was a bit of that, which is, okay, I'm going to do everything I can to try and succeed with this. I'm going to start working on it a year in advance. I'm going to study everything, watch everything, read everything.
你只是做好工作。哦，肖恩。阿门，兄弟。谢谢，阿门。我想对于撒切尔夫人，也有点那种感觉，就是，好吧，我要尽我所能去尝试并取得成功。我要提前一年开始研究它。我要研究一切，看一切，读一切。
And then you'd show up and you just do your best job. And you don't know until afterwards whether people are going to go, oh my God, did you see that piece of like, what was she thinking? Yeah. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. Do you remember that first day of being there with the hair and all of it and thinking like, here we go, fuck this better fucking work cause I am out on this motherfucking limb now.
然后你出现，尽你最大的努力。在事后你才知道人们会说，天哪，你看到那个片段了吗，她在想什么？是的。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。你还记得第一天带着发型和所有的一切在那里，心想，开始了，该死，这最好能行，因为我现在已经骑虎难下了。
That's amazing. I passed on it just so you know. You didn't agree with the I am out on this motherfucking limb now. What's amazing is... I passed on it, just so you know. I was first... You didn't agree with the wardrobe though, that was why. Yeah, I mean... But the thing is, you see her silhouette, you see, you know, the minute the wig goes on, and you get into costume, and you see the silhouette alone. I could have talked like Daffy Duck, and you would have believed I was Margaret Thatcher,
太棒了。我拒绝了它，只是让你知道。你不同意那个“我现在骑虎难下了”。令人惊奇的是……我拒绝了它，只是让你知道。我是第一个……你不同意服装，这就是原因。是的，我的意思是……但问题是，你看到她的轮廓，你看到，你知道，假发戴上的那一刻，你穿上戏服，你单看那个轮廓。即使我用达菲鸭的声音说话，你也会相信我是玛格丽特·撒切尔，
because the silhouette was so spectacular. Had you been, you had already been living in England for a while before you started doing that? Yeah, I'm, so we finished Exfiles in 2002 and I moved back to the UK. We were always going to move back again when I was a kid and we just never did. And so it was always a dream of mine to at least be, you know, part of my life to be back there.
因为那个轮廓太壮观了。在你开始做那个之前，你已经在英国住了一段时间了吗？是的，所以我们在2002年结束了《X档案》，我搬回了英国。我们小时候总是打算搬回去，但一直没能实现。所以这一直是我梦想的一部分，至少是我生活的一部分，能回到那里。
So I went back and I did a play and then stayed. And so I've been living there since 2002. Wow. And was there extra pressure playing Margaret Thatcher being a resident now? Like, cause you know, being in America, you could play Margaret Thatcher. And maybe if it did go sideways,
所以我回去了，演了一部戏，然后就留下了。所以我从2002年起就一直住在那里。哇。扮演玛格丽特·撒切尔作为现在的居民，是否有额外的压力？就像，因为你知道，在美国，你可以扮演玛格丽特·撒切尔。也许如果它真的搞砸了，
you'd get a little more space between, you know, those who might criticize. I think so, I think because, you know, most of the theater work that I was offered as a young person were British plays. You know, I did the philanthropist, I did Abs and Friends, you know, off Broadway, I did all that, I kept because of my accent,
你会得到更多的空间，你知道，那些可能会批评的人。我想是的，我想因为，你知道，我年轻时被提供的戏剧作品大多是英国戏剧。你知道，我演了《慈善家》，我演了《阿布斯和朋友们》，你知道，在外百老汇，我做了所有这些，我保持着，因为我的口音，
because that was basically my first way of speaking, was with a British accent. So that was easy for me. And so I was, in living in the UK, they've kind of adopted me from quite early on of being back there as a professional person, post-Exfiles, as being a, they've taken me on as being one of them in a way.
因为那基本上是我说话的第一种方式，是用英国口音。所以这对我很简单。所以我在英国生活，他们从我回到那里作为专业人士，在《X档案》之后，很早就接纳了我，他们以某种方式把我当作他们的一员。
But playing somebody that has that iconic history there in that particular country. She is such a divisive character. I mean, people feel really, really strongly about Margaret Thatcher and not all of it is positive. So in playing her periods there or from over, you know, whether we shot it in the States to be aired there, it would be the same reaction. The people that hate her still hate her and the
但是扮演一个在那个特定国家有那种标志性历史的人。她是一个如此具有争议性的人物。我的意思是，人们对玛格丽特·撒切尔的感觉真的非常强烈，而且并非全是正面的。所以扮演她，无论是在美国拍摄还是在那里播出，反应都是一样的。恨她的人依然恨她，而
people that love her still love her. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's interesting. Gillian, just talk to us for a second. It's quite a responsibility being the person who asked the secret person on. You got to keep the show going. You got to have some questions. Yeah, you got to kind of keep it moving a little bit. Well, I wanna talk to you about your book, Want,
爱她的人依然爱她。是的，是的，是的。很有趣。吉莉安，跟我们聊一会儿。作为那个邀请秘密嘉宾的人，这真是一份责任。你得让节目继续下去。你得有一些问题。是的，你得让它稍微动起来。嗯，我想和你聊聊你的书《Want》，
and I wanted to ask if it came post-doing your show, Sex Education, or prior to, how did that all? Yeah, it came, so in Sex Education, I play, it's a Netflix series, we did four seasons, I play a sex therapist. And in the process of, or during the period of time of being on that show, you know, my character's house is filled with sex paraphernalia
我想问它是发生在你做完《性教育》这部剧之后，还是之前，这一切是怎么发生的？是的，它是，所以在《性教育》中，我扮演，这是一部网飞剧集，我们拍了四季，我扮演一名性治疗师。在拍摄过程中，或者在拍摄那部剧的期间，你知道，我角色的房子里装满了性用具，
and pictures of vaginas and penises and all kinds of tantric stuff on the walls. And I kept taking pictures and so I kept wanting to post these pictures and the girl who does my, because I don't post things myself, she kept saying, you can't post it, this is like a peanut,
墙上贴着阴道和阴茎的照片，还有各种各样的密宗东西。我一直在拍照，所以我一直想发布这些照片，而那个帮我做……因为我自己不发布东西，她一直说，你不能发布它，这就像一个阴茎，
Instagram is not going to let you post a penis. Sean, is that true? That is not true. I can tell you that is untrue. Anyway, I started posting them anyway, and I would do like a yoni of the day or penis of the day, and then people would send me pictures of penises or yonis in nature, like a poodle with the butt, you know.
Instagram不会让你发布阴茎的。肖恩，那是真的吗？那不是真的。我可以告诉你那是不真实的。不管怎样，我还是开始发布它们了，我会做类似“每日阴蒂”或“每日阴茎”的内容，然后人们会给我发自然界中阴茎或阴蒂的照片，比如一只屁股像贵宾犬的狗，你知道。
Yeah, it's nice. So I started this kind of thing. Penises in nature, like a poodle with a bat. Oh, nice, nice. Yeah, it was nice. Aw, penis in nature. So it started this kind of thing. Penises in nature, yeah. Anyway, so my professional life started to mingle a little bit with my personal life in that Instagram. You were getting kick-picks? It's an example of anything to do with my personal life.
是的，很好。所以我开始了这种事情。自然界中的阴茎，比如一只屁股像蝙蝠的贵宾犬。哦，不错，不错。是的，很好。哦，自然界中的阴茎。所以它开始了这种事情。自然界中的阴茎，是的。不管怎样，我的职业生活开始在Instagram上与我的个人生活稍微融合了一点。你收到了阴茎照片？这是与我个人生活有关的任何事情的一个例子。
I don't ever post personal things. So there was a cross-pollination that was happening there. And so people would talk to me, I mean not in a therapeutic way, but a lot of stuff that came to me was, since then, has been part of that bigger conversation about sexual well and particularly for women.
我从不发布个人事情。所以那里发生了交叉授粉。所以人们会和我交谈，我的意思是，不是以治疗的方式，但从那以后，很多传给我的东西都是关于性健康，特别是女性性健康这一更大对话的一部分。
And so in the seventies, Nancy Friday wrote a book called My Secret Garden, and she did the introductions to chapters and she invited women to send in letters to her about their sexual fantasies. And it was a book that, so anonymous letters from women, particularly, mostly in America, writing about their sexual fantasies.
所以在七十年代，南希·弗莱迪写了一本名为《我的秘密花园》的书，她做了章节介绍，并邀请女性寄信给她，讲述她们的性幻想。这是一本，所以是来自女性的匿名信，特别是，主要是美国女性，写关于她们的性幻想。
And it was like a number one book. All of a sudden everybody wanted it. Women were carrying it in their purses. But it was a real insight into, you know, what women think about when they think about sex. And we thought we'd discuss doing a modern day version of it to see whether in the age of sorry, Franny, pornography and shows like Sex Education or Euphoria
而且它是一本排名第一的书。突然之间每个人都想要它。女性把它放在钱包里。但这确实是对，你知道，女性在想到性时会想到什么的洞察。我们想讨论做一个现代版本，看看在对不起，弗兰妮，色情作品和像《性教育》或《亢奋》这样的节目时代，
or where everything is out there all the time and you have access to it. To what degree have fantasies, particularly for women, changed over time? And so I put a call out about a year and a half ago to women around the world to write to me anonymously. Bloomsbury set up a portal so that they could do it anonymously. And we collected about 1800 women started writing letters,
或者当一切都在那里，你随时可以接触到它的时候。女性的幻想在多大程度上随时间发生了变化？所以我大约一年半前发出呼吁，让世界各地的女性匿名写信给我。布鲁姆斯伯里建立了一个门户网站，以便她们可以匿名进行。我们收集了大约1800名女性开始写信，
and we end about 800 of them finished them. And then we've put about 174 of them in the book. Wow, that's wild. It's wild. So some of them didn't finish. Correct. I'm just going off what you... Some of them didn't finish, which is correct. Okay. Now, did you notice a big difference between the content of those sexual fantasies now versus
大约有800人完成了。然后我们在书中收录了大约174封。哇，那太疯狂了。太疯狂了。所以有些人没有完成。正确。我只是根据你说的……有些人没有完成，这是正确的。好的。那么，你注意到这些性幻想的内容与
years ago in the original book? Well, the most interesting thing to me is the degree to which there are so many rules today about what is appropriate and what is not, whereas back then animals show up and... Wow, I think it would be the opposite. Like it would be more permissive today. Yeah, you think it would be the opposite. Like it would be more permissive today. Yeah, you think it would be the opposite. But we've got the most extraordinary letters
多年前原书中的内容有很大区别吗？嗯，对我来说最有趣的是，今天关于什么是适当的、什么是不适当的规则是如此之多，而那时动物会出现，而且……哇，我想这会是相反的。就像今天会更宽容。是的，你认为会是相反的。就像今天会更宽容。是的，你认为会是相反的。但我们收到了最非凡的信件，
from young teens who have yet to have sex, talking about their fantasies to mothers of many children, single parents, and what it's like trying to do the same old, same old with your partner to you know 20-somethings in the dating world and how what exists in their head is different from what they experience out in the real world. You know it's a real it's really interesting and we've got letters from literally all over the world. So there's, we also ask the women, we also invited the trans community
来自尚未发生性关系的年轻少女，谈论她们的幻想，到有多个孩子的母亲、单亲父母，以及试图与伴侣做同样的老套事情是什么感觉，到你知道二十多岁在约会世界的人，以及她们脑海中存在的东西与她们在现实世界中经历的东西有何不同。你知道，这真的很，这真的很有趣，我们收到了来自世界各地的信件。所以，我们还询问了女性，我们还邀请了跨性别群体，
and genderqueer people and yeah, it feels quite egalitarian. It feels, it's- How does that word mean? Equal. Egalitarian, oh, okay. Yeah, it feels like it's an equal opportunity for anybody to pitch in and to talk about their
和性别酷儿群体，是的，感觉相当平等。它感觉，它是——那个词是什么意思？平等。平等主义，哦，好的。是的，感觉就像是任何人都可以参与并谈论她们的
experience and it does. I heard you got like thousands of letters from an Amanda A from Los Angeles. This is unconfirmed. Very unsatisfied. There was a run on stamps in our local post office. Amanda, where are you going? I'm running to local post office. Um. Amanda, where are you going? I'm running to the post office. I'll be right back.
经历，确实如此。我听说你收到了几千封来自洛杉矶阿曼达·A的信。这是未经证实的。非常不满足。我们当地邮局的邮票被抢购一空。阿曼达，你要去哪？我正跑向当地邮局。嗯。阿曼达，你要去哪？我正跑向邮局。我马上回来。
She's just got a stack of letters. Huh, she's really, um, wow, well that's, that's uh, that's, wow, what an awesome. That's really cool. Yeah, it is a cool thing. It's really, uh, it's a really interesting insight. I would have thought that porn would have showed up a lot more in the fantasies.
她只是有一堆信。哈，她真的，嗯，哇，好吧，那是，那是，哇，多么棒的。这真的很酷。是的，这是一件很酷的事情。这真的是，嗯，这是一个非常有趣的洞察。我本以为色情作品会在幻想中出现得更多。
There's a lot of, There's a lot of women, no matter how intense the fantasy gets, at the end of the day, just wanting to be seen for who they are, just wanting to be held, wanting care, wanting somebody to look in their eyes, wanting, you know, or the or, you know, the opposite woman who by day are in charge of 500 employees and, and the CEO of this, that and the other, and they just want somebody else to be in control. So, so they, you know, and so it's just, it's, it's fascinating. It's well, why are you crying?
有很多，有很多女性，无论幻想变得多么强烈，归根结底，只是想被视为她们自己，只是想被拥抱，想要关怀，想要有人看着她们的眼睛，想要，你知道，或者，你知道，相反的女性，她们白天负责500名员工，是这个那个的首席执行官，她们只是想让别人来控制。所以，所以她们，你知道，所以这只是，这只是，这很迷人。好吧，你为什么哭？
Well, I'm not crying. I'm saying it's dusty. I'm just saying, hold me. Gillian Anderson, you have been more than generous with your time on what I imagine is your day off. And so thank you so much. Thanks for everything. Been such a fan of yours for the longest time. It was very sweet.
嗯，我没哭。我是说有灰尘。我只是说，抱抱我。吉莉安·安德森，你在我想象中是你的休息日里，对你的时间表现得非常慷慨。所以非常感谢你。谢谢你所做的一切。长期以来一直是你的粉丝。这非常贴心。
Yeah, and your new book, Want, is out now. Did you do an audio version of that book? Yes, but it's not me, so. Cool it, baby. LAUGHS Do you read the letters? Do you? So I wrote the introductions to each chapter,
是的，你的新书《Want》现在已经出版了。你为那本书做了音频版本吗？是的，但不是我读的，所以。冷静点，宝贝。笑声 你读那些信吗？你读吗？所以我写了每一章的介绍，
and I read the introductions, but then there are women, other women, who read the fantasies. Got it. Copy. We'll send Jason the audio. Jason. I can't get the hang of the reading.
我读了介绍，但然后有女性，其他女性，读了那些幻想。明白了。收到。我们会把音频发给杰森。杰森。我读不来。
It's top to bottom, left to right. Sure, sure. Um. Jillian, thank you honey. It was very nice to meet you. Thank you, it was so nice to meet you guys. Great to meet you too. I'm a fan of your show and yeah, thanks for your time.
它是从上到下，从左到右。当然，当然。嗯。吉莉安，谢谢你，亲爱的。很高兴见到你。谢谢，很高兴见到你们。也很高兴见到你。我是你们节目的粉丝，是的，谢谢你的时间。
All right, enjoy the rest of your time in Calgary. Bye, Jillian, nice to meet you. Thank you. Bye, Jillian. Bye, meet you. Thank you. Bye, Jillian. Bye, thank you, thank you. Bye. The great Jillian Anderson. Bye. Bye. Will, nice guest. Yeah, good guest, right?
好的，享受你在卡尔加里的剩余时间。再见，吉莉安，很高兴见到你。谢谢。再见，吉莉安。再见，见到你。谢谢。再见，吉莉安。再见，谢谢，谢谢。再见。伟大的吉莉安·安德森。再见。再见。威尔，不错的嘉宾。是的，好嘉宾，对吧？
Hey, huh? Yes. She is a talent, she's a talent, she's a, I mean, but it's interesting because she did Dana Scully, as we pointed out, her name. Yeah, loved. Character that everybody knows, massive hit, global. Not just one of those shows that was really big here. And then it came back.
嘿，哈？是的。她是一个天才，她是一个天才，她是一个，我的意思是，但这很有趣，因为她演了达娜·斯卡利，正如我们指出的，她的名字。是的，很爱。每个人都知道的角色，巨大的成功，全球性的。不仅仅是那种在这里非常火的剧。然后它回来了。
Huge globally, came back. They made a couple movies in the interim. The movies were good too. But to be able to kind of step out of that and then step into a, and not just step into one more iconic role, but step into like three or four other, or eight or 10 great roles continuously
全球范围内巨大，回来了。他们在期间拍了几部电影。电影也不错。但能够走出那个角色，然后进入一个，不仅仅是进入另一个标志性角色，而是进入像三四个，或者八到十个伟大的角色，持续不断地
and recreate, reinvent herself. Super, super tough to do and super admirable. Yeah, super talented. And by the way, it's always wild. We talked a little bit about it when you associate somebody so much with the character that made them famous, and then you see them in interviews or outside of that world.
并重塑，重塑自己。超级，超级难做到，而且超级令人钦佩。是的，超级有才华。顺便说一句，这总是很疯狂。我们谈到了一点，当你把某人与让他们成名的角色联系得太紧密时，然后你在采访中或在那个世界之外看到他们。
Just her having that t-shirt on, that Wu-Tang Clan shirt, and talking about her, you just see her as, and then Margaret Thatcher, of course, and all the other stuff, you see her as a completely different human being. Yeah, and then she's like this totally chill, cool, really smart, interesting person, yeah. Can we revisit Sean's theory on evolution?
仅仅是她穿着那件T恤，那件武当帮的T恤，谈论她，你只是把她看作，然后是玛格丽特·撒切尔，当然，还有所有其他的东西，你把她看作一个完全不同的人。是的，然后她就像这个完全放松、酷、非常聪明、有趣的人，是的。我们可以重温肖恩关于进化的理论吗？
Yes, I'd love to hear it. I'd love to hear it too, yeah. Yeah, so, okay. So the spaceship's planted? So the spaceship, so do all the humans come out of the spaceship or just two of them and then like sort of like an Adam and Eve, they come down, they're sort of egg-shaped?
是的，我很想听听。我也很想听听，是的。是的，所以，好的。所以宇宙飞船是种下的？所以宇宙飞船，所以所有的人类都是从宇宙飞船里出来的，还是只有两个，然后像亚当和夏娃一样，他们下来，他们是蛋形的？
No, no, we have to, we have to. Me, me, me, me, me. We have to have. Right. We have to have had come from somewhere. Somebody or something made us, right? So it's evolution. All right, Doc, I'm with you so far. But we're not the only planet in the entire universe.
不，不，我们必须，我们必须。我，我，我，我，我。我们必须有。对。我们必须是从某个地方来的。某人或某物创造了我们，对吧？所以是进化。好的，医生，到目前为止我同意你的观点。但我们不是整个宇宙中唯一的星球。
So you're not having this nonsense about the Big Bang, right, all the science stuff is not working for you? No, yeah, for sure I am. Yeah, no, all that works. But I'm just saying we can't be the only species. So because we're not the only species and there is intelligent life. Like if you don't think there's more intelligent life
所以你不是在说关于大爆炸的废话，对吧，所有的科学东西对你都不起作用？不，是的，当然是。是的，不，所有这些都有效。但我只是说我们不可能是唯一的物种。所以因为我们不是唯一的物种，而且有智慧生命。就像如果你不认为有比我们更聪明的生命
than us out there. No, we all, that's not in dispute, but I think people are saying that perhaps these other alien, the alien life form also came from what was originally sort of created with sort of this big bang and who was responsible for the bang. Yeah, but I don't think it's-
在外面。不，我们都，那没有争议，但我认为人们在说，也许这些其他外星人，外星生命形式也来自最初那种用这种大爆炸创造的东西，是谁对爆炸负责。是的，但我认为这不是——
You're suggesting that maybe the aliens lit that fuse. Correct, I don't know if it's a who as much as, it could be a what, it could be, but I'm open to anything. Or a spaceship. I'm open to anything, yeah. With a real big exhaust system, right? Yes. Just like, ba-boom, it was some sort of a backfire.
你是在暗示也许外星人点燃了那根导火索。正确，我不知道它是一个“谁”还是一个“什么”，它可能是，但我对任何事情都持开放态度。或者一艘宇宙飞船。我对任何事情都持开放态度，是的。带着一个真正大的排气系统，对吧？是的。就像，砰，那是某种回火。
Yeah, something like that. But you're saying at some point, somebody from Tatooine came here. That's right, that like that. But you're saying at some point, somebody from Tatooine came here. That's right, that's right. Not from Naboo, because give me a break. No, right. But definitely somebody from Camino and Tatooine, they came in, they're like, hey, let's go.
是的，类似的东西。但你是在说在某个时刻，来自塔图因的人来到了这里。没错，就像那样。但你是在说在某个时刻，来自塔图因的人来到了这里。没错，没错。不是来自纳布，因为饶了我吧。不，对。但绝对是来自卡米诺和塔图因的人，他们来了，他们就像，嘿，走吧。
Jakku, you're thinking about Jakku, not Nobu. That's a sushi restaurant. Sorry, Jakku, no, Jakku, yeah. I'm not talking about Nobu, Malibu. You know, it's funny, Jacku, no Jacku, yeah. I'm not talking about Nobu Malibu. You know, it's funny, my cousin, he's from, my cousin's from, he's from Alderaan and he... And he... Well, I'm sorry about his passing,
贾库，你在想贾库，不是纳布。那是一家寿司店。抱歉，贾库，不，贾库，是的。我不是在说马里布的纳布。你知道，很有趣，我的表弟，他来自，我表弟来自，他来自奥德朗，他……而且他……好吧，我很抱歉他的去世，
they blew up the whole planet. They blew up that whole planet. Don't know stuff about it. Yeah, Alderaan. Stop knowing shit, none of it's real. You may find it when ready, remember? So if you know everything, Sean, then what would you call someone who's got dual citizenship like she does?
他们炸毁了整个星球。他们炸毁了整个星球。不知道关于它的东西。是的，奥德朗。别再知道那些狗屁了，那都不是真的。你准备好时可能会发现，记得吗？所以如果你什么都知道，肖恩，那么你会怎么称呼像她这样有双重国籍的人？
You know, she's from, she's got England, she's got America. Well, you might call her. What would you call her? You might call her bi-coastal. No, no, it's not coastal. It's not coastal. Oh, not fucking bi-coastal. Get back to the microphone.
你知道，她来自，她有英国，她有美国。好吧，你可能会称呼她。你会怎么称呼她？你可能会称呼她为“双海岸”。不，不，不是海岸。不是海岸。哦，不是该死的“双海岸”。回到麦克风前。
She would be bi-what? Bi-coastal. Coastal That's not coastal it's not Get back to the microphone. She would be by what? By what do you mean anything but coastal motherfucker? It's two countries, bro. It's Bilingual no no by what no it's they don't speak English. I don't know I listen I don't know the answer, but I want something better than by coastal Guys hang on it. Will's got guys, hang on, it's Sean. Will's got it. Hang on, Sean, Will's got it. Here we go.
她会是双什么？双海岸。海岸 那不是海岸，它不是 回到麦克风前。她会是双什么？你说的双什么是什么意思，除了海岸，混蛋？这是两个国家，兄弟。是双语，不，不，双什么，不，它，他们不说英语。我不知道，我听着，我不知道答案，但我想要比“双海岸”更好的东西。伙计们，等等。威尔有，伙计们，等等，是肖恩。威尔有答案了。等等，肖恩，威尔有答案了。开始了。
Sean, Jason, you guys, you guys are at odds right now, and I want you to be in the... I want you to be more in sync, and I want you to be, bye, bye, bye. Don't move the microphone away like that's got it. Bye, bye, bye. It's like the podcast version of a mic drop. Don't move the microphone away like that's got it. Bye. Bye, bye, bye. Like the podcast version of a mic drop. Off of Nsync. We're going to appreciate the effort on that and judges will allow.
肖恩，杰森，你们，你们现在意见不合，我希望你们在……我希望你们更同步，我希望你们，再见，再见，再见。别像那样把麦克风移开，好像有答案了。再见。再见，再见，再见。这就像播客版的麦克风掉落。别像那样把麦克风移开，好像有答案了。再见。再见，再见，再见。就像播客版的麦克风掉落。离开Nsync。我们会欣赏那方面的努力，评委们会允许的。
Bye. Bye. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
再见。再见。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。少。
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbicoe, and Michael Granteri. Smart Less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。少。SmartLess是由Rob Armgerve、Bennett Barbicoe和Michael Granteri 100%有机且手工制作的。Smart Less。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。